so this is it we're just like off-brand
Bo Burnham now
I'm into it good morning Hank it's
Tuesday
I continue to be astonished by the
likelihood that somebody behaving like a
first name bunch of numbers on Twitter
or Reddit will actually have a first
name bunch of numbers username you want
to know something weird The Fault in Our
Stars came out 11 years ago today what
what a strange 11 years it's been
sometimes when I'm really stressed out
I'll think like you know what though
like you're not a computer no wonder
you're anxious like you're a monkey
wearing a jacket trying to make a
YouTube video what a strange situation
to be in but right about the Fault in
Our Stars it makes me really happy to
know that people are still finding that
book and reading it as a story instead
of as like part of some larger cultural
phenomenon that includes Saturday Night
Live skits and everything it's just so
lovely that it is still in print and
still finding people it's been around
almost as long as the Doritos Locos Taco
hey so this is a literary device called
foreshadowing lately I've been thinking
about the fact that throughout history
most people had absolutely no idea what
was going on inside of the body like
there was this doctor and a few hundred
years ago he published a paper that was
like what happens when a human being
swallows a pin we don't know it might
come out of the tummy it might come out
of the leg it might come out in the pee
it's a magic and that makes me wonder
like what do we not know that would be
very obvious if only we had a way to
know it
hi everybody thanks for coming to my
show tonight you know what really grinds
my gears prepositions people will be
like you live in a country but on an
island because countries are made of
human ideas whereas islands are
inelectable Geographic realities but if
I'm not mistaken like it's all an island
like this is a water planet with some
islands on it it's all just human
constructs like if you zoom out Earth
itself is an island in an ocean of space
everything is an island we're not living
on Earth or on the continent of North
America we are living in these things I
demand an end to the tyranny of Oneness
sometimes I read this stuff on the
subreddit I'm 14 and this is deep and I
think actually this is kind of deep and
y'all are just jaded this is the chair
where I write all day I'm used to
looking from it not at it but it's it's
a good little chair and it's got my
favorite painting right there and I can
just look at it and I am carried away
lately I've been making these strange
little wobbly closed forms hold on let's
cut to the pottery lab I'm very much a
beginner at Pottery but basically I just
take a lump Clay Center it as best I can
and then make a closed form that is
hollow on the inside like when they're
drying they look like this and then
after they're glazed and fired they look
like this the idea is that these are
secret Keepers like you whisper things
that are difficult or worrisome or
traumatic or whatever into the little
holes in the bottom and then the worry
or trauma lives inside of the closed
form and not inside of your head does it
work no probably not but I like it
conceptually and then when I'm all done
making the secret keeper and I've
whispered the secret into it I kind of
like holding the pottery in my hand and
looking at it and thinking
oh wow
I survived you
Hank thanks for keeping it fresh for 16
years and counting I'll see you on
Friday